blank party house
with hans and white
yes yes that's right party house
we are very many
political parties have parties office
but we are even smaller
but does not have to be large either
so we want party house
then we work very efficiently
yes with hans cane is right
who am I satisfied with
ester old hand of party for the animals
oh hey nice to talk to you
yes yes yes we are also very sorry for the animals
that's right then you are at the right place
what you want to call for
submit a motion for the animals after the elections
well we go with it
and where does it go then
for the polar bear
the polar bear yes that polar bear
we fully support that
yes yes no problem
no problem
oh you have one more
also for the sheep
the sheep yes I understand
yes also beautiful
that light fur
so blank animal
we can,
yes,
yes
oh you also want to go straight to the cow
yes,
I have to consult with Hans
because
yes that is such an animal with all those spots
yes I don't know if we can ignore that
we are blank of course
the bird of paradise
esther listening ever
that is such a creature with all those colorful colors
he says blank
yes no you should not stay busy there
ok we are really for the animals
but it must be blank
yes then we can
all don't go no
now you are disappointed
sorry but yes we have to
what do you say are you done with it
well I think that's a shame
but good
yes that is not possible
a pity that is not the case
sticky state